[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Ladies and
gentlemen, Regina Dugan,
Vice President of Engineering,
Advanced Technology,
and Projects at Google.
[APPLAUSE]
REGINA DUGAN: One year
ago, on June 26, 2014,
you met ATAP, a small
band of pirates trying
to do epic shit by closing
the gap between what if
and what is.
A team that is mobile
first, lean and agile,
open, optimized for speed.
We wanted you to
know that about us,
but what we wanted
you to remember
about us is that ATAP is full
of doer-dreamers like you, who
dare to try even when
it means we might fail,
and that doing so is
terrifying and hard,
because it is authentic and
human and scary to believe
and dream and do.
Now, we've spent a
year in that feeling.
We are reminded every day that
we face a choice, play it safe
or go for it.
We push each other.
We push ourselves.
Because it's not easy,
but it is what matters.
It's why I'm here, and I
suspect it's why you're back,
why we all go back.
And I don't mean to I/O. I
mean to that terrifying place
where you take the risk
and you make something new.
So we're going to go for it.
No holding back.
Welcome to ATAP.
Game on.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So what kind of trouble have
we made in the intervening 11
months and three days?
A lot.
We've crashed more
than a few Aura phones,
because that's what
happens when you're
revving a new engine for a race
that is fast and worth winning.
Add furious to fast, and you
get storytelling Justin Lin
style, our first live action
360 degree Google's spotlight
story.
We're making a mobile movie
theater and it opens today.
[APPLAUSE]
Now we got a little impatient
with the false choice
between the ever shrinking
screen size and rich user
interactions, so we created
new materials for wearables.
Now that would be
enough for today,
but we're also going to
talk about our continuing
efforts in
authentication, as we made
the move from
tattoos to completely
passive authentication.
Our early results hint at a
time when passwords and PINs
are considered the relics
of an inconvenient past.
Yeah!
Yeah.
And we're going to show
you big mobile security
in a very small micro package.
Now to accomplish this, our
internal team of fewer than 100
has built a global network
of partners measuring 1,000.
In the last 11
months, the number
of ATAP external partners
has grown from 305 to 514,
from 22 countries to 27, from
three continents to five.
That means every day in ATAP, on
average, we sign a new partner.
That's innovation in
the open on steroids.
We seek these
partnerships because we
believe that the answer
is out there, somewhere,
if we are humble
enough to find it.
In every ATAP project we
see the inherent creativity
of others at work, from
Oscar winning storytellers
to system engineers,
musicians to mathematicians.
Our lean internal
team gives us speed.
Our external
partnerships give us
scale and expertise not
available in our small team.
Together we have the ability to
solve hard problems, problems
you can't solve by yourself.
You might say that
ATAP has the spirit
of a startup, the
agility and scale
that comes with a global network
of the best minds in the world,
all with the daring of Google.
OK.
Now on the day that we released
the abstract for this breakout
session, which as you
know, said jokingly
we're going to introduce
wearables that we
hope will blow your socks off.
We mean this more literally
than you might think.
That day the ATAP on reddit
went something like this,
"Smart socks confirmed."
[LAUGHTER]
"What, is there a self
destruct feature?"
"It just displays how smelly
your feet are on your watch..."
Now, we've been talking about
wearables for two decades,
maybe longer.
And whenever I've seen a field
where many smart people have
worked for a long time
and we've struggled
for big breakthroughs,
it's been because there
are some underlying scientific
principle that we're missing,
and if we can find it, it
might unlock new strategies
or opportunities.
We asked this question
about wearables,
and here's what we discovered,
a work from Paul Fitts.
It was entitled "The Information
Capacity of the Human Motor
System."
It was written in June of 1954.
That was six years after
Shannon's seminal work
on information theory,
and many people
were beginning to use
information theory
to explain things that they
hadn't understood before.
Now Fitts used
these basic concepts
from Shannon's theory to
demonstrate that our brains
and bodies combine to
create an information
system with a certain capacity.
Now, there were controversies
about this Fitts' work
and nuances to it,
but that science
taught us something
interesting about wearables.
Let's look.
If we look across the
x-axis as screen size,
this is tablets,
smaller smartphones,
against the y-axis-- this is the
load on the human motor cortex
system, measured in
bits per second--
and if we look at the dependency
between these two things
for the human body, this
is what we discover.
Now how did Fitts measure this?
What he did is he took two
bars a certain thickness
and a certain distance apart,
and he asked his subjects
to tap between those two bars.
Now, while they're thick and
far apart this tapping task
is easy.
And when they're thin
and close together,
this tapping task is
hard, and that's what's
represented by this red line.
Now if we look at the limit that
is imposed by the system that
goes from my shoulder to
the tip of my finger, which
is the system that I use to
interact with most consumer
electronics devices,
what I find is
that it intersects this red
line in an interesting place.
Now Ivan Poupyrev, he also
revisited this, and discovered
something similar.
Now what does this tell us?
Right at that intersection,
we find the screen size
of a smart watch.
So what we learned from that is
that as the screen size shrinks
to the point where we
can put it on our body,
we are approaching the
limit of our ability
to interact with it.
Now, we have two projects that
Ivan will talk about today,
Project Soli, which
seeks to break
this tension by increasing
the bandwidth of the system
that we use to interact,
and Project Jacquard,
which seeks to create
a larger surface
area in which we can interact.
Now, Ivan has been working
on these technologies, ones
that blends digital and
physical interactivity,
for a good portion
of his career.
And there are efforts to
ease the interaction burden
through voice and
gesture, but Ivan
is going to show you
something very different.
Two projects, Project
Soli and Project Jacquard,
which seek to break this
fundamental tension.
Ivan.
[APPLAUSE]
IVAN POUPYREV: Thank you.
Thank you.
So let's talk
about Project Soli.
Our hand is an
amazing instrument.
It's very fast and
precise, particularly
when we're using
tools that require
full dexterity of our fingers.
The sensitivity and accuracy
is very natural to us.
We use it every day.
We don't even notice it.
But we're still are
not able to capture
this sensitivity in
our user interfaces,
which are still quite clunky.
There are many reasons why
fingers and using fingers
for manipulation is superior.
For example, if you
measure the bandwidth
from the cortex to the
tip of your fingers,
it's 20 times the
bandwidth to the elbow.
So what if we can capture
this power of fingers,
these powerful capabilities
of hands and fingers,
and use for user interaction?
What kind of
interfaces can we build
for wearables or other devices?
I have been asking these
questions for a long time.
Now, one approach is to
give everybody a tool.
Give everybody a pen,
and go with that.
Not scalable.
What we propose instead is
that you use your hand motion
vocabulary, familiar hand
motions you learn from tools
you're using every day,
for the interaction.
For example, we all
learned this motion, right?
We use our mobile
phone all the time.
We manipulate this every day.
And we don't have
to learn it again.
It's very intuitive.
What if we remove
the mobile phone,
and only leave the motion which
you already know, and then
this motion-- decoupled
from the physical device,
decoupled from
the mobile phone--
can be used to
control other devices
and becomes more generic input
modality for everything else?
It doesn't have to be
only virtual touchpad.
There's a multiple of motions.
There's a broad vocabulary
of motions which
can be created by your hand.
Your hand can become
a variety of controls,
such as a virtual dial, a
slider, or anything else.
So note how haptic
feedback came naturally,
because your hand provides you
haptic feedback while using it.
So these are very powerful
physical metaphors
which we're already
aware of, and they
can form an interaction
vocabulary that
can be applied to
multiple contexts of use
for multiple devices.
For example, you can use
your virtual touchpad
to control the map on the watch,
or you can make a virtual dial
to control your radio, volume on
the radio, go through stations.
Multiple things you can do.
So what we propose
is your hands can
be complete self-contained
interface control, always
with you, intuitive, easy to
use, and very, very ergonomic.
[APPLAUSE]
In fact, it can be the only
interface control and only
interface device that you
would ever need for wearables.
All physical controls
replaced by your hand.
Now to accomplish
that we need a sensor,
and not every sensor would work.
What we need is a
sensor that can capture
subtle little motions
of your fingers
that are overlapped in 3D space.
Because we want to put it
into the small devices,
such as wearables, it has
to work through materials,
it has to go through
materials, work day and night,
and be small enough to
fit into the device.
So we also don't want
to instrument the user.
We don't want to put
things in your hand.
So we have to go-- so we
looked at the electromagnetic
spectrum, the entire one,
and we still couldn't
find anything appropriate.
You know, capacitive
sensing is very nice,
but it cannot track 3D.
Cameras would struggle
with overlapped fingers.
However, in between
these two extremes,
there's a sensor which
is almost perfect,
would fit all our
requirements, and that's radar.
The radar can do almost all
of that, all of the things
I talked about,
fast, precise, can
work through materials, all
of that, except for one thing.
It doesn't fit in a watch.
[LAUGHTER]
And I have to make it
smaller, otherwise it's
not going to be wearable,
and that's kind of hard.
So we didn't have to start
with a dish, thankfully.
This is our first prototype.
It was about this
size, on a table.
And then over the
course of time we
worked with our partners
and industrial collaborators
to go through many
prototypes like that.
And today we have our
first gesture radar
that is small enough to
fit into the wearable.
Here it is.
[APPLAUSE]
A radar in the pocket.
So this is a new category
of interaction sensors,
running at 60 gigahertz,
that can capture
the motion of your fingers and
hand in free space, touchless,
at resolutions and speeds
not possible before.
And you don't have to be
an RF engineer to use it.
Everything is inside--
antennas, control electronics,
and we can make it at scale.
When we connect
it to a computer,
we can run it at speeds up
to 10,000 frames per second.
And because we have fast
and furious here at ATAP,
as Regina mentioned, we went
from the first prototype
to this chip I just
showed you in 10 months.
[APPLAUSE]
So it's not only
hardware that matters.
The real essence of the
radar, the reasons of it,
is in the signal.
So originally we
think about radar
as something like an echo.
You know, you send
the signal, it
bounces back from the object,
come give you a signal return.
However, to capture the
complexity of the hand
motion, the close range,
what you would have to do,
you would have to have narrow
beams scanning the entire hand
in real time, which is very
expensive both hardware
wise and computationally.
We cannot do wearable
radar this way.
Instead, what we do, we
illuminate the entire hand
with a broad beam,
and the chip receives
signal of a complex
superposition of reflections
from different
parts of your hand
as it changes and
moves in space.
And as the hand
moves, you can see
that the shape of the
signal will change.
So we track changes to
the signal, the change
of the signal, and
estimate the shape
of the hand from
the signal changes.
And now, to explain
how it worked,
I would like to
invite onto the stage
Jaime Lien, our lead research
engineer and radar expert.
[APPLAUSE]
JAIME LIEN: Thank you Ivan.
The radar signal contains a lot
of complexity and information
about my hand when it's
in the field of view.
We have a short
demonstration showing
how we interpret and
extract this information
for gesture sensing.
Let's start with the raw radar
signal shown in this plot here.
This one signal actually
contains a lot of information
about my hand's size,
shape, pose, and dynamics.
You can see how responsive
it is to any slight motion.
So how do we capture
all of this information?
We first transform the signal
into various representations
which help us to visualize and
understand the radio waves'
response to my hand.
For example, on the left
in the range Doppler image,
the specular reflections
off of my hand
are mapped according to
velocity and distance.
If I move my hand up and
down over the sensor,
you can see this
little ball of energy
tracking my motion very finely.
And if I start
wiggling two fingers,
suddenly we can resolve
two moving components
instead of just one.
Similarly, we have
other transformations
which help us to interpret
immediate changes in the signal
phase and amplitude,
as well as frequency
dependent electromagnetic
phenomena which
depend on my on my
hand's size and pose.
From these signal
representations
we can extract features which
directly measure my hand's
characteristics and dynamics.
These features are
fed into machine
learning algorithms
which interpret them
into gesture labels.
And now, the sensor can tell
if I'm wiggling my fingers
or holding still.
[APPLAUSE]
So you can see at each
stage of this pipeline,
we abstract more and more from
the original radar signal as we
extract more and more concrete
information about the gesture
that I'm performing,
and we'll be making
this entire pipeline available
to developers in the API
that we're building.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
IVAN POUPYREV: Thank you, Jaime.
So this is the world's
first radio frequency sensor
for use for touch and
gesture interactions.
So we talked about all
these small, tiny gestures.
Let me try to show you
another demo where we actually
try to do this.
This is very early work.
It's just off the-- Like,
we just finished a week ago,
I guess, so--
So first of all, there's the
detection of the hand, right?
So the radar can detect the
presence, can lock in your hand
or lock out from your hand,
can lock onto the hand.
And now what I'm trying
to do is to control--
directly map motion
of the hand--
[APPLAUSE]
See how precise it is.
This is direct mapping,
where I map one to one.
So even tiny motions like this
produce exact larger motions
on the screen.
So I can control this
little blob really,
really precisely with just
tiny motions of my fingers.
Now this was uninterpreted
motion of my hand, right,
direct mapping from the
motion of the fingers
to the control on the screen.
So now we do some
simple interpretations,
which allows you to do things,
controls, and gestures.
I can do it really, really fast.
[APPLAUSE]
So this is on some of
the machine learning
and intelligence we can build
into the user interfaces.
What's exciting about
the radar is that we
have multiple modalities.
I can construct
gestures and distance.
So in the next demo, I can
create multiple controls
separated in space.
For example in this
case, I can control
hour-- what time is it-- I think
about 9:00 or something, no?
OK, 10:00.
And here we can control minutes.
[APPLAUSE]
And I could go back to hours
and control hours again,
and I can control minutes again.
I can do that all day.
Now, let's not forget
this is not just
a microsensor and micro
gesture sensor, right.
It can do a lot of things.
It can be a natural
gesture sensor.
We made a small
game, a soccer game.
I can push the ball.
[APPLAUSE]
Yay.
I actually rigged this
game so I always win.
I can't lose in this game.
So, back to the project.
So in Project Soli, our
what if became what is.
We built a sensor
that's small enough
to fit into the wearables,
a new sensor that
would fit on the wearables,
but powerful enough
to capture the
exquisite manipulation
capabilities of your hand.
It's a very powerful
and new sensor modality.
We're working on
finalizing developing
of the brand of the
board and software API.
We'll then be applying to
release to developers later
this year, so that you too
can begin to experiment
and play with this
new sensor modality
and create amazing things.
[APPLAUSE]
So let's move to
another project.
As we you may remember from
the earlier slide which Regina
showed with the graph,
there are two directions,
one to increase the
capability of the sensors
for the interfaces
through using faster
and better manipulations,
interactions using our hand,
and the second one,
to increase the space
where we can interact.
So let's talk about
Project Jacquard, which
approaches this problem.
So Project Jacquard
is about textiles.
The idea for the project comes
from observing similarity
between multitouch
panels that we use
in mobile phones and textiles.
Both are interlocking grids.
Therefore, if we
can replace some
of the yarns in the textile
with conductive yarns, what
we can do is to weave
multitouch textile sensors.
We can weave multitouch
panels, weave them.
They are flexible,
colorful, tactile,
made of silk, wool, cotton,
any other materials,
like any other textile.
You can weave interactive
deductive input devices.
And if we make a garment
out of such textiles,
it would be immediately
interactive and responsive,
and you would not
call it a wearable.
You would call it a jacket.
So we have seen instances of
interactive garments before.
People have done this.
But we want to move
beyond novelty.
We want to move beyond
the single case use cases.
We want to make interactive
garments at scale,
so everybody can make them
and everybody can buy them.
And when you go
this direction, we
have to think about
multiple clothes.
We have to think about different
clothes from multiple brands.
So we have to think about
making interactive textiles
at the scale of the global
apparel fashion industry, which
sells 19 billion garments a
year, which is 150 times more
than mobile phones.
We cannot expect the global
fashion industry to change just
for us, even though
we're Google.
We have to make interactive
garments possible
using existing manufacturing
techniques and existing
manufacturing supply chains.
We have to adapt the
textile industry,
so that every textile
mill in the world
can weave interactive textiles.
So can you really manufacture
interactive textiles--
inductive garments, for
this reason-- at scale?
So that's the question.
We travelled the world.
We went to multiple
countries, Japan, Europe.
We learned about industry.
We made friends.
This is one of our
partner mills in Japan.
It turned out that the very
basic fundamental technologies
and materials that are
required to manufacture
interactive textiles
simply are not available.
You cannot buy
them off the shelf,
so we had to invent them as we
were building the capability,
starting with the
conductive yarns,
conductive yarns that can
withstand the harsh industrial
processes of textile
manufacturing, getting woven,
burning textiles with open
fire, stretching, washing them,
and pulling them
with metal claws.
I said to myself, this is not
very friendly to electronics.
So another problem was
the choice, a choice
of colors of materials.
This is an example of a
catalog of yarn swatches
which textile designers
use when they make fabrics.
This is the choice
of conductive yarns.
Comes in one color, gray.
And it's not even
that conductive.
So we had to go and to
invent our own yarns, which
you see in this
picture, not only that
are hundreds of times
more conductive,
they could withstand all
the burning and pulling
forces of textile manufacturing,
all those conditions,
but also look and
feel completely normal
to a textile designer or to you.
They look indistinguishable
from normal yarns.
However, if you look at
them with a microscope,
you will see that
in fact there are
complex molecular
structures where
highly conductive metallic
alloys are braided together
with thin silk fibers to give
this yarn supreme strength
and durability, and
at the same time
we can make it in
multiple colors.
So let me show a video of how
this textile-- how these yarns
are made.
So you can see from
the center, you
can see the conductive core
comes in, and is braided around
with a sleeve of additional
yarns, which gives it strength,
but also can be of any color.
It's a heavy industrial process.
This is a very different
experience from programming.
This is multiple
colors which we can
produce with our
manufacturing approaches.
Now, the challenge of
producing interactive textiles
is also about connecting
them to the digital world.
It's not just to make textile
and be happy about it,
but you want to actually use it.
So when we made the first
textile, we were very naive,
and we just made this
whole thing interactive,
all 20 meters of it.
But this created a
connectivity problem.
How do you take this textile
and connect it to electronics?
So we tried brute force,
more brute force, then
a little bit less brute force.
But it still didn't
work, because you
have to pull out each
of the yarns by hand,
and it just doesn't work.
So what we did, we went
back to the original idea,
went back to the
craft, and thought
how can you weave
interactive textiles in a way
so it's easy to
connect electronics,
not the other way around,
how does electronics
attach to the textiles.
So we went back to our partners
in the textile industry
and figured out how can we can
weave our patches precisely
where we want them to
be, to localize them,
so the problem is
localized in one place
not on 20 meters of textile.
Or the [INAUDIBLE], which is
a three dimensional weaving
technique, so we can change
directions of the yarn,
going from the top surface
of the yarn to the bottom
but then free float outside,
so that we can access them
with tools and machines
required to make connections.
At the same time, we're able to
keep the structure of textiles,
the structure of
the yarns intact,
so that we can connect the
yarns in the correct order.
So the order of correct
connection is very important.
So at the end we get
something like this,
and that can be connected
to electronics really
easily and without any effort.
So let me show how interactive
textiles are woven.
There are many,
many moving parts.
This is one of our
partners, one of the experts
in textile manufacturing
and textile design
in Japan, one of the best ones.
So you can see our yarn coming
in, our conductive yarn.
And you see by weaving the
interactive panel coming out.
This is our yarns inside.
This is the woven
panel coming in.
And we can place it anywhere
we want on a piece of textile,
and we can do anything you like.
So using this
established process,
we can weave interactive
touch panels.
They don't have to be gray.
They can be any color and shape.
Contemporary designs, there's
interactivity woven there.
Classics.
Transparent.
Invisible.
Stretchable.
And of course we can
make it on any size.
We can weave interactive
panels as large as you want.
And now we can connect
the interactive textiles
to the digital world.
We can connect them and
control our devices with that.
So let me show a
demo of how it works.
First of all, let
me show the textile.
This is a piece of textile
you so on the video.
This is how it looks like.
It's real.
It's not-- you know.
There you go.
This is the back of the textile.
You we can see we cut out
the yarns to separate them.
And now I'll show how it works.
You can see the green,
and as I approach it,
you see the black square.
Over here.
Yeah, here you go.
That is the interactive area.
As I approach it in my
hand, you can see it moves.
[APPLAUSE]
So you actually
see the difference
between our work
and a touch panel.
Again, it's designed to
sense your entire hand,
because you don't expect people
to use their fingers when
they interact with
their clothes like this.
But you also can use
fingers, of course.
Here we go.
[APPLAUSE]
So you can draw.
You can write something.
A. You can do
multitouch like this.
You can do the little waves
across the textile, like this.
Different directions
like this, too.
To wave to you-- wave at you.
So we don't expect these
textiles to be replacement
of the touchscreens.
The material properties of the
cloth are completely different.
It's something you can put on
your body, or on your couch,
or on your pillow, or any
place you use textile.
And then it becomes attractive,
not by precise manipulations,
but using broad
gestures of your hand,
when you just swipe across
and control anything
you would like to control.
So what we're doing right now--
switch back to the slides--
we are building the
entire pipeline.
We are going
through the textiles
from the yarns to the
textile structures
to connectors to wireless
connectivity, mobile systems,
and then to applications
and services which you
can control with the textiles.
This is a website where you
can follow our progress.
Please follow us
and let us know what
you think, because what
we're trying to build
is an ecosystem where people
can design applications
for this technology and
build new services based
on soft computing, soft,
flexible, textile computing.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, the story would not
be complete-- Oh, sorry,
wrong clicker, here we go.
So the story would not be
complete if you actually
try to build a garment.
How do we know that we succeed?
And the only way to know
that, that you can succeed,
is to actually make a
garment-- interactive garment--
and we give it to
a tailor to do.
Not yourself.
Somebody else has to do it.
So we went to
London, Savile Row.
We had a long renowned
history of bespoke tailoring.
We went to a tailor and gave
him interactive textile,
rolls of interactive textiles,
and asked him to make a jacket.
And that short movie
will show the experience.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Creating jackets is a
200 year old tradition.
It's a craft and art.
People learn from
generation to generation.
The tools and
materials, they don't
change as much as we're used
to in our digital world.
It's all about feeling
how you cut it,
how it feels on your hands.
So we gave them
the new material,
our interactive textile.
They were very excited,
because rarely in this industry
something new and completely
different comes in.
It's an industry built on
tradition and craft and respect
for the craft and
respect for traditions.
The brands we're working
with have been around
for-- a lot of the
brands have been around
for hundreds of years.
This is connecting-- they
designed a little pouch
to put the electronics.
Close it in.
It's a jacket come to life.
Swipe across the sleeve
to make a phone call.
[APPLAUSE]
Your jacket has arrived.
And you can see this jacket
right here, me wearing it.
[APPLAUSE]
I actually quite like it.
So it's about how to combine
technology and fashion,
and making things
fashionable and beautiful.
There's the answer.
Now, we think about
Jacquard as a raw material
that will make computation
part of the language which
apparel designers and textile
designers and fashionistas
speak.
We want digital to be
just the same thing
as quality of the yarns,
the color you use,
how digital it is.
And we cannot do
it by ourselves.
We have to, and we wanted
to, work with creatives
from the fashion industry.
And today with us is our first
partner, a historic brand,
sister San Francisco company.
It was here long
before we arrived here.
They came with the gold
rush and built a company
by designing functional and
fashionable, highly innovative
garments.
Our partnership is a
continuation that tradition,
and that's Levi's.
[APPLAUSE]
And I would like to introduce my
colleague, Paul Dillinger, head
of global product innovation
from Levi Strauss company.
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL DILLINGER: Thanks, Ivan.
Thank you.
Thanks.
This is really, really exciting.
As a kid, when I decided to
become a fashion designer
at 12, this is not the company
I thought I would be keeping.
I did not anticipate
playing in this sandbox
with these pirates.
This really-- this is great.
And none of the future that
we're experiencing right now
was imaginable.
So science fiction,
not too long ago.
This opportunity, this
extraordinary pioneering spirit
that ATAP embodies, it makes
me think about our own history
at Levi's.
Levi Strauss was
a German immigrant
who decided to go west
with the gold rush,
like so many other people, to
find his fortune in California.
And he was a dry goods
purveyor, selling the supplies
to the miners going up into the
gold fields near Sutter's Mill.
And the miners were
wearing cotton pants,
right, and they
were falling apart.
They were ripping at
these stress points.
And there was this
point of innovation,
where Levi Strauss and
his friend Jacob Davies
discovered that if they could
use a copper rivet to create
a point of strength where there
had been a point of weakness
that they could
solve a real problem.
And there's an
interesting symmetry here.
The use of a metal
alloy, copper,
from an unexpected place,
an unexpected technology,
machine tools, creating
strengthened apparel.
There's a nice
symmetry of innovation
between what's happening here
at ATAP with Project Jacquard
and what happened at Levi's
nearly 150 years ago.
And I think if Levi Strauss
was here with us today,
looking for the next
gold rush, there's
a lot in common between Silicon
Valley and Sutter's Mill.
We think about the optimism,
the creativity, the energy,
the excitement around invention
that these two cultures share,
and it's only appropriate that
these two great global brands
rooted in San
Francisco come together
for an exciting
opportunity like this.
Now the question is why.
You know, when you think
about the innovation,
yes, the dazzling
opportunity that we
see in this new technology.
Yes, this great platform
that's been enabled.
Yes, but why?
I would think
about this, and all
of us working on this project
would think about why.
I mean, I'd be driving to work
in the morning thinking why,
and some guy would cut
me off because he's
texting while driving.
I would think about why as
I'm biking around the city,
struggling to get my navigation
function from my phone
as I'm navigating the
grid of San Francisco.
I'm sitting at dinner
and I'm looking
at someone else at a sitting
across from their partner
and their phone buried in
their-- up to their face.
Phone to face, that's
a why right there.
We live in a beautiful,
richly textured, real world,
but at ever increasing
need and engagement
with the digital
world, and these worlds
exist with a certain tension.
If there's a chance to enable
the clothes that we already
love to help us facilitate
access to the best and most
necessary of this digital
world while maintaining
eye contact with
the person we're
eating dinner with, right?
This is a real value.
[APPLAUSE]
If we can deliver that value
in the form of the clothes
that you as friends and fans
of this brand already love,
that is a project worth doing.
But as a fashion
designer, it's not
really a project that I'm
entirely equipped to take on.
We've got the genius pirates
at ATAP who can help us develop
and deliver this platform,
and now we have all this great
capability at Levi's.
We've got experts in fabric
creation and supply chain.
We've got designers who can
help us bring this form to life
and the merchants
who can package it up
and bring it to the consumer
in a really compelling way.
But there's a third
creative constituency
that we must activate.
And so now, my friends, you
are all fashion designers
along with us.
[APPLAUSE]
You have the-- We can tailor
a few specific applications
for the exact
consumer that we know,
but the real opportunity
is the creative unlock
in this community to activate
this new platform in ways
we have not had imagined, and
it's going to be iterative
and it's going to
be fast and fun.
And we've inviting you to come
along on this journey with us
as the fashion
designers of the future
to make something really special
happen with Project Jacquard.
All right?
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah?
Cool.
Thank you.
REGINA DUGAN: That's great.
Thank you, Paul.
And with us today is James
Curleigh, or JC as we know him,
president of the Levi's brand.
JC?
[APPLAUSE]
When I spoke to
JC this Wednesday,
he told me that at Levi's they
were focused on two things,
driving their iconic
brand and innovation.
And last week, on the 142
year anniversary of the 501s,
they found a 130-year-old
pair of Levi's from the 1880s.
That's iconic.
And this week, we
announce our partnership
to work on new wearables.
That's innovation.
So congrats, JC.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, Ivan's project
makes it possible to have
more intuitive interactions
with your mobile devices.
But if you have to enter
a PIN or a password,
it sort of spoils the mood,
because authentication sucks.
Passwords suck.
We forget them to
our frustration.
We reuse them to our peril.
We need better methods,
and squirrel noises
are not scalable.
[LAUGHTER]
70% of users forget their
password once a month.
We try, on average,
2.4 passwords
before we have the right login.
Humans are a bad
source of entropy,
the entropy we need for
security, because we need
patterns to remember things.
In the last few years
we've seen the emergence
of dedicated sensors
like fingerprint sensors.
New phones have them, but
what if your phone doesn't?
What if instead of
a single sensor,
we could use a combination of
sensors that would allow you
and your interactions
with the device
to become your authentication?
Your key stroke patterns--
not what you type,
but how you type, your patterns
of speaking-- not what you say,
but how you say it--
this combination,
with local-only processing,
might provide not only stronger
security guarantees, but
do so completely passively.
And not as a binary
single, yes no score,
but as a continuum of trust.
This next frontier
of authentication
moves the burdens of
PINs and passwords
from the user to the
device itself, thereby
trading human cycles
for machine cycles.
Now, might we use advances
in machine learning
to ensure that only you
can access your security
sensitive information,
and do we have
proof points that would lead us
to believe it's even possible?
We saw promising results
from individual research labs
across the globe.
Single modalities, like
gait and keystroke patterns,
but none even as secure
as a four digit PIN,
and mostly demonstrated on
small, laboratory scale,
data sets.
We hypothesized, however,
that if they were sufficiently
independent, they
might combine to offer
authentication better than
fingerprints or even passwords.
To solve for multimodal
authentication,
though, we needed an
interdisciplinary research
team, recruited from
13 universities,
and a large comprehensive
data set for them to work on.
Now, ATAP exists at the
intersection between a driving
application and
ambitious science,
and Deepak Chandra's
project, Project Abacus,
has illustrated the
benefit of this commitment
over the last year.
We needed the ability to get
our partners in universities in
to work with us faster than
the typical 9 to 12 months.
So in June of 2013, we signed
a multi-university research
agreement with eight of the
country's top universities.
Last year at I/O, that
eight had turned into 16.
This year, 16 is 33, including
international universities.
We can now partner with any one
of them in less than 30 days,
and we did.
A team of 25 experts
from 16 institutions
traveled from 10
countries to facilitate
the cross-pollination of ideas.
They joined us in Mountain View
for a 90 day intensive research
sprint.
Our data set was built
from 1,500 data donors
who signed up to contribute
their smartphone sensor
information.
By the end of this study, we had
created a 40 terabyte research
data set, as far as we know,
the largest of its kind.
And we assembled 360 cores
across three clusters,
pulled all of the power
from the first floor,
and dropped power
from the second.
The result?
Proof of the hypothesis.
A new method of
authentication that
may prove to be
10-fold more secure
than the best fingerprint
sensors, with only a software
update.
The hope is that we can
provide this level of security
to millions of Android devices.
And we want to move
beyond phone unlock
to allow an application's
authentication
needs to be individually
met using a system wide API.
The result might look
something like this.
Throughout your day, a
continuous trust score,
running while you type, walk,
browse-- not what you do,
but how you do it--
to allow access
to a game, which might require
little or no authentication,
or a banking app, which
might require much more,
an authentication system
that accepts you and rejects
impostors, in real
time, on device.
Now on the right
side of the screen,
you see two of our
researchers, Hung [? Tai ?]
from Columbia
University and Sujeet,
from the University of Illinois.
They are using a
research debug interface
to show you how this
system might detect
an impostor through
differences in typing patterns
and other signals.
Now, these results are
hot off the sprint.
So we're continuing development,
and hope that in the future,
from high security
to low security,
developers and
users will choose.
Now, better
authentication is only
part of the better
security story here.
Project Vault is a hardware and
software isolated environment
in the form of a microSD card.
It can be used from
mobile to desktop
to the internet of things.
Mudge and his team have jammed
a security dedicated computer
into a microSD card, with a
simple, driver free interface
and a suite of
encryption primitives.
Project Vault will enable secure
communications and storage,
initially for enterprises,
eventually for individuals too.
As our smartphones have
become more capable,
the code that runs
them does too.
Large code bases made
by humans have errors.
Errors may be
exploited to place some
of our most
important information
at risk, like encryption
keys, sensitive documents,
or the sensor parameters
that I just mentioned.
There's an inherent
tension between the desire
to create capability
and the ability
to secure the very code that
drives those capabilities.
Think of it like this.
My home has windows and
doors, a porous boundary,
which is necessary for people
and things to come and go.
But those windows and
doors make it harder
for me to protect
everything in the house.
So I use a vault to store
the most sensitive documents.
It cannot store all of
the contents of my house,
but it can store my most
precious possessions.
Project Vault is your
digital mobile safe.
Big security, small package.
Now, Mudge formerly
led the L0pht.
That was the hacker group
that in 1998 famously
testified to the Senate
that they could shut down
the internet in 30 minutes.
He was the original
author of L0phtCrack,
the password cracking software
that drove operating system
security for years thereafter.
And project fault
is his program.
Mudge?
[APPLAUSE]
PEITER "MUDGE" ZATKO: Thank you.
Thanks.
So Project Vault is a small
microSD form factor device.
It's a separate
ultra-secure mini computer.
You plug into any system
that has a microSD card
slot or an SD card
slot, and make
use of the suite of
cryptographic services
to manage your data needs,
from encrypting data at rest
to encrypting
streaming end to end
communications, like
messaging, voice, and video.
Only you can unlock it, and any
information and the algorithms
inside Project Vault are
never exposed to the system
that you plug it into.
So the question
is, why build this,
and why a microSD form factor?
It turns out you already
have security elements
in your phones and your
computers, SIM cards.
They protect the things that
are important to the carriers,
trusted platform
modules, or TPMs.
They protect the things that
are important to the OEMs
and the content providers.
These are services with very
low bandwidth, a few bits
per second, and with
minimal storage, measured
on the order of kilobytes.
So where's the
security element that
protects the things that
are important to you,
that you have
complete control over?
So we made one.
[APPLAUSE]
We needed a little
more throughput,
because we wanted to be able
to handle encrypting video.
So at a bare minimum, one
megabyte a second streaming.
We wanted it to be modular
so that you could take it
with you from device to device.
We also wanted gigabytes
worth of storage for use cases
like immutable logging systems.
Now, an immutable
logging system can
be a really powerful
deterrent to an adversary,
where the evidence
of their activities
are forever captured
on a separate security
computer in a way that can't
be tampered with or altered.
Our first focus
is the enterprise,
because if it works
for the enterprise,
it'll work for the individual.
What you're looking at here
are the actual first versions
of Project Vault in
microSD form factor.
We're deploying about 500
of these within Google
for authentication
purposes, supporting things
like Project Abacus,
that you just heard about
and the aforementioned
immutable logs.
Inside this little device
is an ARM processor
that runs our security focused
real time operating system,
or RTOS.
It's got an NFC
chip and antenna,
same thing that's in your
contactless payment systems.
However, we're using it
so that you could actually
prove to Project Vault that
you are in control of it
and that it is authorized
perform sensitive processing
on your behalf.
We've loaded it up with a suite
of cryptographic services,
hashing, signing, bulk
encryption, streaming
encryption, a strong
hardware random number
generator, and four gigabytes
of isolated sealed storage.
To Vault--
[APPLAUSE]
Oh.
Thank you.
To Vault, users
can communicate end
to end without exposing any
cryptographically sensitive
data to the host
systems, and this
provides a consistent
set of security
features regardless of
how secure or insecure
the host system
might be, and very
importantly, in a way that's
easy enough for any novice
to use.
So what do developers
have to do to get
their phones or their laptops
or internet of things devices
ready to use Project Vault?
Nothing.
The host system just thinks this
is a regular storage device,
but actually that's
just an illusion
that we're creating on the fly.
So to geek out for
just a moment, when
we get the request, we gin
up an artificial disc label,
a master boot record, the
file allocation table.
We populate it with a read
file and a write file.
We mark all of the
other blocks as bad,
so that you can only interface
with these two files.
You want to ask of a
service from Project Vault,
you open up the write file.
You send in your request.
You want the cypher
text coming back out,
you open up the read file.
It's a procfile system
without any kernel drivers.
[APPLAUSE]
The fewer drivers that you have
to load up on the host system,
the less of a security risk
you pose to the host system,
and more importantly it makes
us operating system agnostic.
It doesn't matter what version
of Android, iOS, Chromium,
Linux, Windows, you have.
You just plug it
in and it works.
[APPLAUSE]
So that's what we're
experimenting with inside ATAP
right now, and it's still very
much in the experimental stage.
But what we're releasing
today for everybody else
is the full source code for our
FPGA-based developers platform.
So it's all Apache 2.0.
This includes the Verilog
and VHDL and all the code
for the security based
RTOS, the SD controller
firmware to allow communications
with the host systems, the NAND
flash translation layer
so you can manipulate
the sealed storage, my
personal favorite, the hardened
and accelerated
hardware crypto cores,
and the interface description
language so you can talk it.
In fact, even the
processor on this
is open source,
the OpenRISC1200.
[APPLAUSE]
We're doing this to be fully
transparent, because we want
developers to be able
to see how it works,
understand it, trust it,
and also then experiment
with pulling certain
sensitive applications outside
of the general purpose
operating systems
that you're used to writing in,
because these devices might be
untrusted or just too
complex to ever fully secure,
and now you have an external
isolated execution environment
to run them in.
So with that, I'd to
invite Tim Carstens up,
my colleague who's done a
lot of the Verilog VHDL work
for these dev boards,
[APPLAUSE]
If I can get the
camera up, we're
going to run a little demo.
I'll log you in here.
Oh, I hate passwords.
Made a living off of
them for a while, too.
Oof.
So, on this side-- if the camera
can focus in on the laptop--
we're looking at a chat server.
So this is a chat
server running out
of the East Coast,
essentially the Gods-eye view.
There's nothing there
right now, because we're
going to see the
communications as they come up.
On the right we have, of
course, Bob and Alice.
So Bob and Alice both have
a Project Vault device.
So if we could have Alice plug
in the Project Vault here.
There's the file system--
the illusionary file
system-- with the read file
and write file there to see.
So at this point, Alice would
launch a chat application,
and the chat application
just opens those two files
to make use of Project
Vault. And if we
go back over to the laptop,
please, with the camera,
if the demo gods are
happy with us today--
and it appears that
they are cooperating--
this is the cypher text.
So all the cypher
text on the server.
So what's happening
is Project Vault
is ingesting this,
decrypting it, looking
for the hello messages
from each other,
from the contexts that are,
again, stored in Project Vault,
engaging in key negotiation,
setting up a session key,
and once that's done they
have an encrypted secure
communications channel.
So if we're back
over on the phones,
we're going to send some
messages back and forth.
The server, or any third party
only ever sees the cypher text.
The phones display to the users
the decrypted communications,
but none of the secrets,
none of private keys
or the actual algorithms
that are operating with them
are ever exposed to the
device it's plugged into.
[APPLAUSE]
So it shouldn't matter
how many doors or windows
your house has, as long
as you have a vault in it.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much.
REGINA DUGAN:
That's big security
in a very small package,
but Spotlight Stories
seeks to give you
big movie experiences
through the mobile window
that used to feel like just
a smaller screen.
We combine traditional
storytelling
with interactive
elements in a way that
preserves the
emotional connection
of a linear narrative.
Now it's not often you
get to be present when
a new creative format is made.
Henry Jenkins, founder of the
MIT Comparative Media Studies
program explained
that once we introduce
a medium, a mode of human
expression, into the universe,
it tends to persist.
Live theater persists
in the face of cinema.
Radio persists in the
face of television.
That's why it feels special,
because a new format has
a certain timelessness to it.
Last year, Disney
legend Glen Keane
completed 10,055
original drawings
to create "Duet." "Duet" was
our third Spotlight Story,
and a few months after I/O,
"Duet" shipped to millions
of users on Motorola phones.
The first wave of
press coverage was
in the tech and Android blogs.
Then "Duet" attracted
a bit of attention
in the entertainment community,
and the artistic community
recognized "Duet" as well.
There was Oscar
buzz, and "Duet" at
was nominated for an Annie,
the highest award in animation.
It won the film industry's
award for best original score.
And while millions saw "Duet"
through a small mobile window,
lucky passers by saw it on
the largest screen in the US.
We flooded times square with
Scot Stafford's original score,
and for a few minutes,
in the rain and the cold
on Christmas Eve,
people slowed down.
In 2008, Jeremy Hsu
wrote an article
in Scientific American entitled
"The Secrets of Storytelling--
Why We Love a Good
Yarn," and in it
he said that storytelling is
one of the few human traits
that are truly universal across
culture and all known history.
People in societies
of all types weave
narratives, and when a
characteristic behavior
shows up in so many
different societies,
its roots may reveal something
about our evolutionary past.
Simply put, we are
wired for stories.
It's part of being human.
We long for new ways to
experience and engage
with stories, and storytellers
look for new outlets.
In Spotlight Stories, we
found the answer right
in front of us.
Hundreds of millions of
powerful media devices,
millions more shipped every
day, with ever more beautiful
screens, powerful graphics,
and precise sensors.
Please welcome Jan and Rachid,
quite the pair, creator
and director of the original
spotlight story, "Windy Day,"
Jan Pinkava, and with
him Rachid El Guerrab,
the technical project lead
for Spotlight Stories.
Their goal?
More great stories, more happy
viewers, push the format.
Gentlemen.
[APPLAUSE]
JAN PINKAVA: Thank you.
How you doing?
RACHID EL GUERRAB: Thank you.
Thank you.
So everybody wants more
stories, but we can't make
them all ourselves, of course.
So how do we enable
more creators
to create these kind of stories?
As developers, we of
course create an SDK.
In our case, it's a
Story Development Kit.
Now--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
For this to enable
filmmakers to create content
for mobile, which is
a different space,
this SDK has to fit within
their familiar film production
pipeline.
So for example, we integrate
with standard animation
modeling tools like Maya, and
we support standard technologies
like Pixar's opensubdiv surfaces
and the Alembic geometry
format from Sony and Lucasfilm,
except these run normally
on render farms and
big servers, but we
have to run them in
real time, on mobile,
and at 60 frames per second.
JAN PINKAVA: Now for me as
an animator and a director,
that all looks like
fairly familiar territory,
but the SDK also
has to be a bridge
to the unfamiliar landscape
of a new form of storytelling.
Now the stories are
interactive and immersive.
They're real time,
continuous, and they feel more
like shooting a movie
than watching one.
The flow is affected by the
attention of the audience.
That means they have to
be structured differently
in both time and space.
You have to replace
the traditional film
language of cuts and
shots with new techniques.
For working with this
interactive story structure,
this SDK has a Story Editor.
Now, let's say I
want to make sure
that the audience sees a
key action, like here, Pepe
about to pick up his hat.
One technique is to make
the story wait for you
until you're watching.
With the Story Editor
I can tell the action
to pause, and until your
camera is pointing at Pepe,
and then the action continues.
Very simple.
In this way, the story
is interacting with you.
When we're planning a
story, we use storyboards.
But it no longer
makes sense to have
just a sequence of storyboards,
as if the action is playing out
on the screen.
In an immersive story, we
have a window onto a world
all around us, and we have
to deal with that space.
So our 360 storyboard tool
lets you place the boards
all around you, so that you
can work out the story in space
as well as time.
[APPLAUSE]
And we can't stop at
building these tools.
We have to put them in
the hands of storytellers,
making it real, making it
work as part of their process.
And a growing number of
award winning filmmakers
are exploring this
new territory.
[VIDEO  PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Working in a
virtual world where
the audience is essentially the
camera changes things for you
as a director.
-We are trying to predict
the curiosity of the viewer
and make it all
feel very seamless.
-So I thought, well,
what if could structure
it like a song with
chorus and verse?
-You're kind of giving
your control back
to the audience, which I thought
was a really interesting idea.
-You can't just put a
traditional story on this.
You're going to have to
think a lot about narrative
in a different way.
-Everything from the tools
that we use to the way
we write stories and
the way we lay out
narratives is going to
change and become something
exciting and new again.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
JAN PINKAVA: Now, they're
not just making stories,
they're shaping the format.
By using the tools,
they're making the tools,
by telling us what
they need to do.
And of course, great
storytellers need an audience.
RACHID EL GUERRAB:
So now we have
to scale the distribution
of these kind of stories
and get them to more viewers.
So this week, we launched
the Google Spotlight Stories
app for Android, and very
soon after will be for iOS.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Where you can find curated
stories by great storytellers,
you can share them
with your friends,
and look behind the scenes.
And this summer,
we're on YouTube.
Our interactive format supported
natively in YouTube mobile.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So now filmmakers have the
means to make these stories,
and we can put them at
the hands of hundreds
of millions of viewers.
Done.
We planned our vacation.
Then somebody had to ask,
what about live action?
What are you doing there?
And so, that somebody
was Justin Lin.
[APPLAUSE]
And when Justin saw "Windy
Day" the first time,
our first story,
he was instantly
intrigued by this
idea of telling
stories that
surround you, but he
wanted to do it in his own way.
He wanted a full Hollywood
cinematic experience
with high production
value, in 360, on mobile,
and that, of course,
created new challenges,
and goodbye vacation.
So first, we had to
figure out the camera.
For his films, Justin needs
professional grade cameras
that can capture at high
resolution, in low light,
at night, and with
fast moving action.
Now we have to do it in 360.
And with our partners
Bullitt and The Mill,
we looked at every
360 camera system
out there to find one
that could make the grade,
and it just didn't exist.
So we had to build it.
Our rig uses four RED
Epic Dragon cameras
with eight millimeter
fisheye lenses from Canon,
capturing at 6K resolution each.
So you can see there Angus,
the creative director
from The Mill, looking a little
bit worried about all that data
coming out of the cameras.
We created a custom casing
that reduces the overall rig
size and the offset between
the nodal points of the lenses,
which is very important
for 360 video stitching,
but also helps with
tasks in post production
and visual effects
down the line.
But of course, it's not
enough to just build the tech.
We need to make sure
that Justin can direct
with it on the set in 360.
So we set up onset live
stitching and streaming
to 360 monitors with real time
feedback on custom mobile rigs,
so that Justin can see what the
camera sees at every moment,
and what the viewer might see.
Now we have to put it
all together for you
and deliver it to your device.
And to do that at
full resolution
with cinematic field of view
means streaming, decoding,
and rendering the equivalent
of three 4K videos at once.
That's like three
ultra HDTV streams
coming through your phone.
Of course, few if any
devices can handle that.
But it turns out
that only at most
about 25% of that data
is actually needed
at any one time,
because that's all
you can see through your phone.
And so we implemented a
dynamic spatial tiling system
that would process only
what's visible and adapts
to your device's
horsepower in real time.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Those tiles are decoded
in multiple resolutions
and then blended together to
adapt to your view in motion.
So there's no blocking,
stuttering, or janking,
whether you're turning
really fast or moving slow.
JAN PINKAVA: So it's all
about what you're seeing.
Now, for a filmmaker,
telling a story
is about directing the
attention of the audience.
You see this gesture
all the time.
This is what I want
the audience to see.
And some things are
important to see
or to hear so that the
experience actually
makes sense as a story, right?
In a traditional
movie, the story
has been completed
in the edit suite,
and the audience
knows where to look.
You just watch the screen.
When watching an
immersive story,
the audience is free to look
around just about anywhere,
and sometimes it's
easy to get lost.
So we developed camera
composition and tracking
techniques that help
you stay with the action
without ever dictating
where you should look,
just as a gentle
guide that still
leaves you free to point your
camera wherever you want.
Whether you like to look
around or just sit and watch,
we're there to help
you enjoy the ride.
Now to complete the
picture, we need
to complete the
sound experience.
How can we bring the richness
of immersive theatrical sound
to the mobile world?
In a movie theater,
everyone looks
in one direction--
at the screen--
and the sound experience can
be created with a fixed speaker
layout.
In our format, you can
look in any direction,
the story world
is all around you,
and the speakers
are your headphones.
The sound in your
ears now must change
you turn, just like real life.
To get a truly interactive
and immersive experience
that responds to
you, we developed
dynamic virtual surround.
Using techniques like ambisonics
and binaural rendering
and an end to end
pipeline, sound designers
can now create subtle and rich
and realistic acoustic spaces
of the sort they're used
to in feature films,
but now in real
time, 360 on mobile.
[APPLAUSE]
And for Justin Lin's
story, we created
a full sphere surround field for
interactive film from scratch.
That's a first.
And the soundscape of the
story is now all around you,
and it comes to life only
when you watch the show.
So we're not just putting
you in the picture,
we're immersing
you in the sound,
and all you need is an
ordinary pair of headphones.
Now, we'd love to show you
this and share this with you
right now.
Unfortunately, the
screens in this room
are only big enough
to give you about 15%
of the whole
immersive experience
that you can get with
a pair of earbuds
and the phone in your pocket.
So here's just a taste of it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
REGINA DUGAN: Ladies
and gentlemen,
the writer, director,
and producer of films
grossing over $2
billion, including
the Fast and the Furious
franchise, and, upcoming,
"Star Trek Three" for Paramount,
director of our latest
Google Spotlight
Story, Justin Lin.
[APPLAUSE]
Awesome, Justin.
And because it's taken some
serious storytelling partners
to get us here, I
want you to meet
some of the other
creative talent that
helped make Google
Spotlight Stories,
and continues to create
in this new mobile format.
Let's welcome back Jan Pinkava.
[APPLAUSE]
Jan won the Oscar
for "Geri's Game"
and was the co-director
for "Ratatouille."
Jan is the creative director
for Google Spotlight Stories.
And Karen Dufilho, double
Oscar winning producer,
who along with Jan continues
to carry the Spotlight Stories
creative frame.
Now, Jan and Karen
have been here
from the beginning, when
our makeshift studio in ATAP
was a conference room
where we posted up
artboards that had been
transported awkwardly
in an engineer's car.
And the man who challenged the
new with the old, hand drawn
animation in mobile, is back.
Glen Keane--
[APPLAUSE]
--animation legend and creator
of our third Spotlight Story,
"Duet."
Our Story Development Kit
guinea pig and resident nutcase,
Shannon Tindle.
[APPLAUSE]
Shannon won a prime time Emmy
for individual achievement
in animation, and he's working
on our fifth Spotlight Story.
Think science fiction Icecapades
with an unsuspecting visitor.
And finally, because
what else would
you do after winning an Oscar
but a Google Spotlight Story,
Patrick Osborne--
[APPLAUSE]
--head of animation on "Big Hero
6" and winner of the 2014 Oscar
for the best animated short.
Justin, Jan, Karen, Glen,
Shannon, and Patrick
are here for a box talk right
across the hall, 11:00 AM,
second floor, alcove three.
Thank you.
Awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
And, well, that's a wrap.
Almost.
[APPLAUSE]
Creating the hardware equivalent
of the software ecosystem
is hard.
In the last months, we've moved
from the industrial design
to functioning prototypes to
our first engineering spiral.
We've moved from FPGAs
to ASICs, and we're
starting our third spin.
Rafa Camargo is our
lead system engineer,
with responsibilities for
hardware and software.
He's accustomed
to mobile firsts.
He led the first Android
platform at Motorola.
He's been at the forefront
of nearly every generation
of mobile technology.
And now, he's on Ara.
Rafa.
[APPLAUSE]
RAFA CAMARGO: Thank you.
Project Ara is all
about letting you decide
what your device is, and does.
So let's see how it works.
Let's try this.
This is the frame.
We call it the endo.
And these are modules.
Let's just connect them.
This is an
application processor.
I just connected the battery.
That's a speaker, and
this is another speaker.
I want my ARA in stereo today.
Enabling all of this is what we
believe to be the first UniPro
switch network, and running
it all, is [? GreyBox ?].
[APPLAUSE]
Here you go.
Ara, running the
latest Android version.
Let me show you something else.
Let's launch the camera.
Of course, I already
know that today I
didn't configure a
camera, but let's see
how easy it is to
add new hardware
functionality to your device.
This is a camera module.
I connect it.
And it's that simple.
There you go.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So why don't we take the
first public picture with Ara?
[CHEERS]
All right.
All right, guys,
smile for the picture.
[CHEERS]
Let me see.
Oh, you all look awesome.
OK.
Thank you.
Follow us on our
Twitter account,
Project ARA, where we'll have
updates on our next developer
conference.
[APPLAUSE]
REGINA DUGAN: Can we have
just a moment, please?
Because what just happened?
We assembled a smartphone
on the fly, booted it,
run time detected a camera,
and took your picture.
[APPLAUSE]
That's nuts.
Artists and musicians,
scientists and engineers,
we are more the same
than we are different.
We share a deep
satisfaction that
comes from creating something
that never existed before
and a certain exhilaration
when that something connects
us, makes us better, celebrates
the inherent curiosity,
the vulnerability, the joy, and
the sorrow that makes us human.
That kind of work,
it is inherently
born of the human spirit.
It is a little
badass and beautiful.
It is tech infused
with our humanity.
And it doesn't have love
sprinkled on at the finish.
The work itself is an
expression of love.
That's what it feels like
to us, in this fast boat,
in this small band of
pirates, trying as best
we can to do some epic shit.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]